I am so excited and it's officially
official we are making it beep to all
the Boise right now in the circle we are
so excited it's happening the world of
getting more Lana condor and more noah
sandton ayo aka your favorite on-screen
couple Peter Kaminsky and Lara Jean as
an early Christmas gift to well all of
us Netflix officially announced the to
all the boys I've loved before sequel
with this two cute video almost done
with my Christmas list for Jenny I'll
just make our favorite chocolate chip
cookies for Noah Noah kind of already
has everything no I I was literally just
thinking about what's key for Christmas
by the way if we're gonna do this thing
we are gonna need a new contract it's
just a Christmas contract well then I
get some into personal I'm not watching
a Christmas horror movie no it's the
Christmas prints 1 & 2 I can definitely
do that no once I get I'll be back okay
hey what you're gonna make the perfect
on Ambrose along with the video
announcement Netflix also wrote this
letter it says in part quote yes you can
seamlessly continue to run your hashtag
Kavinsky fan accounts and quote let's do
this I promise the next chapter will be
worth the wait
et was with Noah just weeks ago he had
this to say about a possible second
flick and where he thought Peter might
be well what can you tell us what do you
know nothing I think it's been reported
it is happening oh well I certainly
don't know what would you like to see
happen in at for Peter yeah I just like
to see him get a sequel you know
hopefully we you know we explore the
darker sides of a relationship he he
enlarged he already had issues
you know but the salvage they made them
they made them work but you know calm
before the storm hopefully you know we
want some drama the sequel is currently
in development it'll be released by
Netflix though no date has been set just
yet one thing is for sure though we're
looking forward to more fireworks
between the two stars she said that you
are a natural flirt and that Lana is a
hopeless romantic now do you feel like
that's why your chemistry is so strong I
think that that goes both ways for both
of us that's just like I'm the flirt
she's the romantic she's the flirt I
don't know it's all of it um I would say
it's it's a little bit to do with one
holidays and they're not sure she is
that's like a really big part of it and
it's just really easy to react and
listen to her when she was just active
in position so so natural and then
another part of it just has to do with
the fact that like I think we have
similar perspectives on life our
outlooks are similar and and we just
like really like to talk and communicate
and we got to know each other really
well so that means I've made it really
easy
[Applause]